[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right our band will play five
seconds of a song they wrote you have to
name the very popular and expensive song
it kind of sounds like but isn't and we
can prove it in a court of law
all right i'm looking for tracy newin is
tracy new in here hey hi how are you
nice to see you how you doing i'm doing
good oh i am very tall and you were very
small hi
oh hi america um how are you nice to see
you where are you from sacramento
sacramento okay thank you for being here
no cheers for sacramento very sad um
now that
that just made it sadder uh
okay tracy here's your clue all right
carly rae jepsen is an adorable singer
but if we tried to play her hugely
popular song on our show she might just
sue us
maybe
band let's hear it
[Music]
all right now what very famous song does
it sound like but it is not that song
um call me maybe call me maybe
yeah
one may think that that song has called
me maybe but i will insist anywhere that
that's our own pop song called join my
linkedin network perhaps
here to perform it is singer and 2012
mtv video music award watcher brian
lafontaine brian
hi
i don't know you
don't think i'm full of crap but join my
linkedin
network perhaps yeah
[Applause]
you are a terrible terrible man and i
hate you i am integrity's enemy
all right well you did win tracy what
prize do we have for tracy andy she's
won a bottle of new jersey governor
chris christie's homemade salad grape
gravy
there you go there's your salad gravy
nice to meet you
later
i'm looking for dan cummins dan cummins
where are you ah he's right behind me
there you go dan comes let's hear it for
dan cummings good to see you
where are you from dan orange county
orange county i like your shirt oh
thanks those are those shirts that uh
charlie sheen wears on two and a half
men those are cool
i like those
very nice good to have you here good to
be here okay you seem scared don't be
afraid yeah i'm very weak feel that arm
you could beat me up in a see that
tell them it's like putting in a sleeve
yeah it's sad
all right dan if we tried to play this
song history lesson by billy joel
without paying for it would have to
prove we didn't steal the fire to his
copyright lawyers
play it guys
all right
what song does it sound like but it's
not so we don't have to pay a dime oh
shoot it's okay i wrote the answer here
in case
we didn't start wow that's incredible
all right
how did you do that
you looked lost and then you just found
it
oh my god
all right that may have sounded vaguely
like we didn't start the fire but for
legal reasons i mustn't sit was a
completely original composition called
it wasn't i who commenced combustion
tom sawyer daniel boone malcolm x walks
on the moon lincoln killed my hand
grenade i flunked out of second grade it
wasn't high that commenced combustion
but i watched it burn on it was quite a
turn on yet
[Applause]
kinda hate them don't you hate him my
own grandmother won't take my calls
terrible performer and a bad guy all
right
andy uh what prize do we have for our
friend here dan well it's something we
found on a guest dressing room it's one
of steve buscemi's contact lenses a
vanity contact lens
what an incredible gift
steve buscemi contact lens that's yours
to have right there
it's also the yamaha of the future enjoy
that
very nice to meet you congratulations to
you i'm looking for a ben pool it's ben
cool yeah
ben
good to see you how are you oh how are
you look at those tats yeah dude those
are great i don't have any tattoos i'm
thinking about doing it would you do it
if i get a tattoo would i do it for you
yeah yeah absolutely what would you
suggest um can i put my face on your
face
yes you may
you heard it here on television how long
is that going to take minutes minutes
you're going to do a rush job on top of
it
there you go it's done guys who make his
living with his face
thanks a lot ben all right you ready to
play yes all right this song by the
eagles is about a certain hotel it's so
well known that if we tried to play it
on the show we'd end up in the courtroom
california
take it away
[Music]
[Applause]
that really bummed me out
that was so depressing all right what
song do you think that is oh that be
hotel california all right
close very close
but the eagles charge a lot of money for
their songs that was not it okay that
was our original hit motel
arizona
go stay at the motel arizona
weekend rates are fair
there's free wi-fi there
this is my yelp review for
[Music]
[Music]
easily my least favorite person in world
history my wife and children agree all
right
what prize do we have for this gentleman
here andy well you can't go wrong with a
giant bag of ketchup
there you go it can't go wrong here
congratulations
really please take care of that all
right